[Music]
Holly's never really left me she was
kind of always there I'm here today and
what terrible crime is that this one so
intimately familiar with the character
Harlequin she loves devoting the energy
time to figuring that out I think that
now getting to play her again is really
exciting for her too and she gets a die
further into the character she came back
like really real quick
[Music]
ready to go
I met with Margo in the summer of 2015
it was a morning meeting on like a
Wednesday and when they were like can I
get your tea or coffee we both were like
yeah I could have like a my mouse or
something and I was like I love this
chick she's not really like cookie
cutter playing by the road and we will
started talking about what we were both
interested in the kind of movies that we
loved and what we both wanted to do she
told me that she had this idea this
dream of doing a Harley Quinn girl gang
r-rated movie and I was like I'm in 100%
1000% I'm in a picture already the
general idea and I think the studio is
they're a little trepidatious especially
when it came to like the operating they
were like what are you trying to do here
now let me bring you a spirit when I got
the script I was like I thought it
couldn't get any more about you crazy
Christina's brain is like really
interesting some of this stuff I'm like
how'd you come on in your little she
really could write like Holly it's me
sane she's so able to catch the tone and
spirited these characters it's like the
cadence of it the words that she uses
she's so tapped in to
how these characters should sound it was
just about having fun really and we kind
of wanted to just explode that and see
what would happen if you didn't follow
any of the rules he didn't do anything
that was expected yes I take my
incredibly seriously it was the desire
for us to entertain the idea younger
filmmakers somebody who could bring a
very unique point of view to this world
we met first in I didn't think I could I
just finished my first feature that was
just starting to get into the system and
figure out what I wanted to do next and
then I read the scripts and it was like
love at first it felt really bright when
Kathy came in she understood the story
the characters she had so many
additional thoughts she can seamlessly
work with in a very artistic realm and
she can follow her heart and she can
hold her own and yet she also is able to
be very focused and organized and
structured about executing on that
vision hold up hold up I'm telling this
a little wrong let's rewind
I love the toner movie the challenge as
a director to get rights because you can
veer into just pure comedy but I want
the movie to have heart and soul in a
real arc for all of these women it's a
story about group of women coming
together through all the zany craziness
to help one another I think so often
women in movies are perceived as being
like competitive relationships rather
than friendships and collaborations and
we kind of wanted to see what it would
be like to have a movie about our
friends those you know late nights at 4
in the morning after a night out eating
tacos you drink right kid
it was more women in front and behind
the camera for sure than any movie I've
worked on telling a story about a girl
thing it's always helpful to have a
female perspective that's a lot of
really talented smart completely unique
individual women it's cool to just look
around and have a combination of all
these women but also seeing all the men
that are really superb in this film we
really wanted Maddie
flippity to shoot it because a he's
incredible but I think Maddie is unique
in the fact that he adapts himself and
they'll filmmaker that he's working with
him for the story that he's telling he
and I just immediately got along I think
we have very similar aesthetic taste
he was just brilliant at providing this
color and energy and kind of visceral
experience that we wanted people to have
I think together we were able to take
some pretty big risks in the way we shot
the movie
[Music]
[Music]
action is super fun it's grounded all
the women have different styles and I
wanted to keep it there I love working
with Jonathan you say via our stunt
coordinator he's amazing and his guys at
8711 JoJo's a super pro and he's so able
to do so many different styles of
fighting and has really been able to
kind of build it out and take away
beyond anything I could have imagined to
put on the page and give them each Flair
and character and personality that comes
across she just wanted to encapsulate
like boo the fun and joy of try to find
fun in the action or doing pieces of
hardcore action with some levity Renee
is much more like talking from the
streets she's a boxer canaries mostly
leg work so she's doing a lot of like
roundhouse kicks and boy time right
we want to make her agile but keep her
kind of grounded to maybe Li use their
arms mostly for defense and their
offenses all kicks huntress is just like
a precise precision like killing machine
guitar a little bit of judo and Jiu
Jitsu a little bit of cry whimsical she
uses 15 nasty hard Li's kind of
everywhere so her style is kind of based
off just being unpredictable I've had to
do a lot of fighting and stunt work and
it's just really beyond anything I've
done before in any other film so that's
been really fun and really like
empowering to feel like I can accomplish
some of those things my body has
definitely transformed and taken a
little bit of a beating those stuntmen
they were fantastic and it was so
supportive
I remember Jojo and JP go hit on and I
go what know him I said and he goes no
do it
[Music]
Kathy is so amazing and same for Margot
she's been so involved for an actor to
have such a creative presence in the
filmmaking process has been really
inspiring for me to watch this whole
thing really was born out of our desired
she is feeling since they 100 beating
heart of this project that brought us
all together this movie owes so much to
Margot this has been a very personal
journey for her I think it's been many
many years in the making so I feel very
honored to be a part of that I feel like
that was just so much I still wanted to
explore the first time around
just so wasn't done it so I'm really
happy I got the opportunity now
[Music]
[Music]